[Musique]
mille nouveaux bus propres d'ici 2022
2023 pour recharger ces bus sont
électriques ou en biométhane 40 de dépôt
devrait être transformé une épidémie de
rhinopneumonie touche le monde et 40 des
cas ont été découverts dans la région
francilienne
les yvelines reste pour le moment
préserver les compétitions sont
suspendus jusqu'au 11 avril
elle la vaccination devait débuter lundi
15 mars dans les pharmacies mais
emmanuel macron l'a suspendu suite à
certains effets secondaires du vaccin
astrazeneca les pharmaciens pointe aussi
des problèmes d'approvisionnement
vaccination toujours à saint quentin en
yvelines des doses supplémentaires ont
été attribués et le vélodrome voit son
nerf central investi par la centaine de
soignants mobilisé 1500 vaccination sont
faites par jour la tension hospitalier
continue elle aussi de progresser
40% des opérations ont été déprogrammés
en ile-de-france au vendredi 19 mars 74
patients se trouvent en réanimation dans
les yvelines
dernière étape des travaux de la rd 30
la passerelle du bois de la cram vient
d'être mise en service à plaisir elle
permet de relier à pied à vélo la forêt
et le parc du château
[Musique]
pas